المزيد من المتابعه بالتحليل مع ضيفنا من
اسطنبول الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
العقيد الركن حاتم كريم الفلاحي اهلا بك
من جديد عقيده الفلاحي عندما نقارن ما
يبثه الجيش الاسرائيلي من بيانات وما تبثه
كتائب القسام من صور وفيديوهات لسير
المعارك البريه ما الذي
نستنتجه نعم لا شك بان هناك اختلاف كبير
جدا ما بين الاشرطه التي تبثها كتائب
القسام وما بين الاشرطه التي يبثها جيش
الاحتلال فهناك اختلاف كبير جدا في هذه
القضيه ولا يمكن ان نضعها في وجه مقارنه
لان هنا نتكلم عن معركه تنقل بالصوت
والصوره وهناك عمليه تدمير لقطعات العدوى
المتقدمه في هذه المناطق وهنا نرى بان
هناك جنود يطلقون النار باتجاهات مختلفه
وهذه يعني شتان ما بين الصورتين انا يعني
في تقديري بانه هذه ال قضيه فشل فيها
الاحتلال فشل ذريع وهي القضيه الاعلاميه
او في تسويق ما يمكن ان يقول بانه نجاح
لانه انا اعتقد بانه ما اظهرته الكاميرات
من تدمير للبنى التحتيه و قتل الاطفال
والنساء هو خير دليل على انه هناك فشل في
استراتيجيه الاحتلال في التقدم في الهجوم
البري منذ 7 اكتوبر والى يومنا هذا فلذلك
انا ارى بان الروايتين تختلف بشكل كبير
جدا هنا ادله قاطعه بان هذه الاسلحه
تستخدم لمواجهه القوات المتقدمه على جميع
المحاور وهناك عمليات عسكريه تنفذ في
مناطق مختلفه من ساحه العمليات وهنا نرى
بان هناك جنود يطلقون النار في اتجاهات
مختلفه ولا نرى احد يرد عليهم من الطرف
الاخر وبالتالي هناك اشكال حقيقي في
الروايه في الروايه الاسرائيليه في مساله
اعطاء صوره حقيقيه لما يجري من معارك على
الارض ولكن هناك اقرار عقيد الفلاحي من
الجيش الاسرائيلي من المسؤولين العسكري
بصعوبه الموقف وصعوبه التحديات التي
يواجهها الجيش الاسرائيلي في هذه المعارك
البريه ولعلى ذلك ما يدفع الكثيرين للحديث
خلال هذه المرحله عن تغير في التكتيكات عن
انتقال الى مراحل جديده تكون فيها
الاستهدافات مركزه ومحدده وليست واسعه كما
هي الان ما المقصود بهذا
الكلام نعم الخسائر الان التي يتكبدها
الجيش هي التي اجبرت هؤلاء القيادات على
التكلم بان المعركه صعبه وان هناك خسائر
يضاف الى ذلك بان بطء العمليه العسكريه
وعدم قدره الجيش الصهيوني على التقدم في
مناطق والسيطره عليها سيطره تامه اعطت
دلاله واضحه بان هناك فشل في استراتيجيه
الجيش في التقدم انا اعتقد بان هذه الحرب
يمكن ان نقول بان هذه الحرب يعني حقيقه
جعلت من الجيش الصهيوني واستراتيجيه
الردعه التي كان يتكلم بها والقوات البريه
ا جعلت منه اضح حوكه في مساله انه قدرته
على تحقيق نستطيع ان نقول تقدم في
العمليات العسكريه فلا القبه الحديديه
قادره على ردع واسقاط الصواريخ التي تنطلق
من قبل فصائل المقاومه باتجاه عمق الاراضي
المحتله ولا الجيش قادر على ان يفرض
استراتيجيه حقيقيه في القتال في المناطق
المبنيه ويستطيع ان يسيطر على المناطق
التي دخل اليها في العمليات العسكريه
دائما توضع الخطط وتسبق هذه الخطط عمليه
استحضارا وتهيئه لهذه المعركه ثم عندما
تبدا الخطط تكون هناك عمليه تعديل لهذه
الخطط ما بين فتره واخرى حسب طبيعه الموقف
التعبوي وحسب طبيعه مجريات العمليات في
ساحه القتال ولكن ما يجري الان هو انه
الذهاب من من فشل الى اخر والدليل على هذا
يؤكده بيان بلومبير ايضا كما تبعنا اليوم
عقيد حاتم كريم الفلاحي بلومبير تقول
استخدام حماس للطائرات المسيره التجاريه
المجهزه بالقنابل كشف ثغرات في الدفاعات
الاسرائيليه نتساءل عن حجم هذه الثغرات
وعن طبيعتها
ايضا نعم في تقديري بان الطائرات المسيره
لحد هذه اللحظه لم تستخدمها حماس او كتائب
عز الدين القسام وبقيه الفصائل الاخرى
استخدام فعال في هذه المعركه وبالتالي نحن
لحد هذه اللحظه نرى بان هناك استخدام بسيط
جدا له لهذه الطائرات خصوصا وان هذه
الطائرات هي صغيره الحجم قادره على التخفي
وقادره على حمل متفجرات بكميه جيده وتوجه
بنظام الجي بي اس والاقمار الصناعيه
وبالتالي يمكن استخدامها بفعاليه كبيره
جدا ولكن لحد هذه اللحظه لم تستخدمها حماس
بفعاليه كبيره جدا في هذه المعركه واتصور
بانه في تقديري بانه قد تكون الفتره
المقبله قد تكون هي شاهده على انه يمكن
استخدام مثل هذا السلاح بشكل فعال في
المعركه وبالتالي نعم الطائرات المسيره هي
مهمه طائره الزواري طائره شهاب ابابيل اي
ابابيل بي جميع هذه الطائرات يمكن لحماس
ان تستخدمها وبقوه خلال الفتره القادمه
خصوصا وان الطائرات التي تصنعها الان فيها
مميزات حقيقيه يعني يمكن الاعتماد عليها
في تنفيذ مهام وضرب اهداف حيويه فلذلك
يعني حتى الطائرات المسيره هي جزء من
التكتيكات التي يمكن ان تستخدم من قبل
كتائب القسام لاداره هذه المعركه خلال
الفتره القادمه العقيد الركن حاتم كريم
الفلاحي الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي من
اسطنبول شكرا جزيلا لك